actually gamers nexus was wrong about
one thing why'd you make me do it linus
why did you make me do it
[Music]
today we're reviewing the rtx 3070 ti
it's
msrp is 600 that puts it 100 above the
rtx 3070
it's coming out one week to the day
after the geforce rtx 3080 ti
and that card launched at 1200 we called
it a waste of money
and said it was 71 more expensive for
about or less than 10 percent more
performance
so now we're reviewing the 3070 ti the
tone has been set
the stage is prepared for the 30 70 ti's
arrival you can see we have
prepared such stage ourselves and in
this review we're going to be looking at
the ga104 silicon
that is a higher quality than the 3070
silicon and the 360 ti
but it's ultimately the same silicon
that's in the three of them and
we'll be going through all the normal
numbers but also unfortunately
uh spending a little bit of time
responding to linus from his wan show
wouldn't normally want to do it but he
did he did sort of drag us into it so
we'll be going through that as well
before that this video is brought to you
by squarespace we use squarespace for
our own gn store and juggle
complex multi-piece orders all the time
with it squarespace makes it fast for us
to roll out new products with detailed
pages full of galleries
videos and descriptors it's also useful
for your own resume sites for
photographer or project portfolios
or for starting your new small business
idea there's never been a better time to
try and start your new business than
right now and we can vouch that
squarespace makes it easy
visit squarespace.com gamersnexus to get
10 off your first purchase with
squarespace since this is a repeat of
the 3080ti
versus the 3080 or 3090 whatever will
sort of start the review with the same
thing which is a time saver
it is a waste of your time to learn too
much about the 3070 ti
because ultimately it's on one hand the
value is not good
and that's all there is to that angle on
the other hand if you are buying one
because you walked into a best buy three
weeks from now and it happens to be on
the shelf
it doesn't really matter what we say
you're probably buying it either to
resell it
or to use it yourself or you're buying
it because it's sort of like
a gas shortage where there's news that
there might be a shortage
and so everybody rushes the gas stations
to buy it all out
so that they don't end up being the
sucker with no gas even though they
started the week
with a full tank this has happened to us
recently on the east coast by the way
so that's what we're looking at today
now uh
the price increase is about 20 percent
here msrp to msrp
that's what that's how we do our reviews
and
the exchange for 20 is a couple of fps
and that couple fps it ends up being
worth about four to five percent
up to about 10 in rasterization it looks
like the average in our suite
is closer to the range of seven to nine
percent and
in rtx it's variable as always you get a
little bit more
at the higher end with a 30 70 ti over a
30 70 all those percentages are based on
a 30 70 baseline so that's what we're
looking at that
we just you know the 3080ti really its
purpose has become clear while working
on the 3070 ti
3080ti is an offensive launch by nvidia
it's obviously a money grab where nvidia
is
boosting its asp because someone in the
shareholder group said
someone on the board said these are
going to be sold out instantly
they're going to resold for a lot more
why don't we take some more of that
since they're going to be purchased
anyway and
reputation be damned we'll make it back
in money and we'll worry about the
reputation later
there's only two of us after all so
what's the harm but following that
fiasco it's become clear
why the 3080 ti exists at least to us
the 3080ti
sort of looks like a decoy product the
3070 ti
star is this making anyone nervous the
3070 ti starts to look like
it offers great value when compared to
the 3080 ti
kind of like the 3080ti looks like value
compared to the 3090 except
you can't ignore the fact that you
shouldn't be buying a 30 90 for gaming
if you're buying it for professional
work like we would use it for
when andrew's working an unreal engine
or blender or something then you need
the vram
and you don't get that with a 3080 ti so
it's not
to us really a clear comparison between
the two of them so then
that's what we're looking at today uh
first we need to talk about
whether or how msrp influences price
before we progress further because we
will be predicating a lot of what we're
saying
on sort of the same points as last week
which is that starting with a higher
msrp
does actually matter and it sets a
statement for what nvidia is trying to
do
it tells us nvidia's goals and it gives
us a firm baseline that's not nebulous
it's not out there in in the ether that
we can actually base things off of when
we're making value judgments because
anything else is just a fool's errand
because we don't know what it's going to
be scalped for so
that's how we we compare things okay so
let's get into this msrp
price influence thing being on camera we
all live in
glass houses uh in this instance
a stone has already come through my
house so i'm just throwing it out
the same hole that it came through linus
and gn were on good terms
and we have disagreements about things
like this editorially sometimes
but just to be really clear up front
this isn't youtuber drama
it's not like beef it's just he's sort
of in his live stream said a few things
about pricing msrp while he was trying
to defend his own 3080ti review which
was poorly received
by some of his audience and he went
unscripted
so going off script in the process he he
referenced us and a few other reviewers
and commented on our reviews
uh we understand linus was again sort of
speaking from
the heart here and was getting uh he was
getting some undeserved hate on his
review
but we do need to address him directly
on saying that we were wrong about
something
i don't know how much used hardware
steve has ever actually bought in his
life
but the way that it works so first up
it's not
used hardware uh we were talking about
the 3080ti
as it's sold as scalped hardware our
statements we made originally
were that the 30 80 ti's 200 higher than
deserved msrp 1200 versus 1000
would influence to some extent the price
at which it is sold
especially scalped on secondhand sites
or
reseller sites like ebay or amazon's
marketplace
places like that that was our statement
so this
would not really classify as used
hardware in this instance when a scalper
sells something
it's not likely to have been used or not
for very long
so people are buying them and selling
them
with the intent to make money ergo msrp
does matter they're not going to sell it
lower than msrp
so it does set a floor that's not
typically
how it works in the in the second hand
or in the in the secondary market
so again not really the second hand
market unless you're playing semantics
about how many hands it has passed
through in which case would be more like
fifth or sixth or seventh
uh so scalpers are buying cards and most
likely not using them and selling them
at a markup the
scalp sales which is what we were
talking about not the used hardware old
hardware sales
will scale on msrp because of that and
that's all there is to it
the way that it works is typically it's
way way more closely tied to actual real
world performance
and what else is available on the market
and that
is the way and that has always been the
way
so something that performs way better
has
more of a value proposition regardless
of what the msrp is
is typically going to be worth way more
i actually don't really
completely disagree with linus here just
the one thing is he did say typically
and it's not a typical market so can't
really draw those comparisons today
just because of how the market is today
and for the foreseeable future the
lifespan of the ti
cards that are out now linus has
purchased more used hardware than
i have he said he's he's correct about
that and that's something that i would
be i'd be happy to go toe-to-toe with
steve on because
i think that is uh just based on
i don't know what he's i really don't
know what he's basing that on honestly
we decided to work with a a script and
pull data
from 93 679 use the gpu sales or
new gpu sales through reseller websites
and use data instead to justify our
position
the total sale value for the cards whose
data we pulled was 71 million dollars
and we were able to analyze that using
strict filters to limit data so for
example knowing we're pulling ti
instead of not ti data or super and
stuff not super whatever
and also we set filters for things like
broken cards being sold only for parts
and filters for things like getting the
fans out of there replacement parts
things of that nature when we posted the
30 80 30 80 ti scalloped prices
screenshot
a week ago linus replied and said it was
too soon to tell for that
and that it wasn't a fair comparison
that they would equalize with time so we
have
stripped the 3080ti versus 3080
comparison in
linus's favor here in the chart we're
about to show we're listing the aib
partner
msrp increase on card a versus card b
where a and b are listed sequentially in
the left of the or in the
the axis of the chart and one bar
represents
msrp the other represents the resale
value when sold
through another website later that would
be something like ebay for example
the closer these bars are to each other
the closer the msrp
is scaling with the resold price and
again that's based off of
about 94 000 gpus that were sold
in this data the larger the red bar is
the more we see
the uh performance versus
the resale value diminish so this
this would be the opposite of linus
argument it would be uh
the angle instead that the price is
going up regardless
of performance even more than we had
suggested originally as you can see here
the 1080 ti
actually gained value at launch it was
around 17 percent higher in msrp from
nvidia
while it has been at 41 higher since
february 1st of this year
that means that the resale or scalped
price has
outscaled the performance uplift and the
original msrp
for the next card the rtx 2080 ti
launched at a 43
higher nvidia msrp than the rtx 2080 but
has had scalped or secondhand sales at
higher that's pretty close to one to one
with msrp the gtx 1070 aib
was uh 52 higher in msrp
than the gtx 1060 six gigabyte aib msrp
nvidia had an fe thing back then
and we see a 58 higher average selling
price
for the 1070 and our data over the 1066
gigabyte when resold that's pretty close
again
the same goes for just about everything
the 980 ti to 980 shows a huge surge in
resale price actually despite
not seeing that big of a performance
increase the 6800 xt and non-xe
reinforce this as does the 1660 ti
versus 1660
and vega 64 versus vega 56. there's one
example we found that
was actually completely in linus's favor
here so linus would be correct with this
one
in that the rtx 2080 launched at 112
percent higher price than the 2060s
initial msrp but that's only being
resold
for 47 more that we think if we you try
to analyze it here it's probably because
there's not really a replacement for the
2060 in today's market
it's the 2060. whereas the 2080 has a
lot of analogs
1080 ti is one of them uh 2080 super
fairly close 2070 super
and then of course the newer cards do
directly slot in to replace the 2080. so
maybe that feeds into it
at this point though we've proven that
msrp is at least
somewhat related to the price it
eventually sells for it's
this isn't that important it's just
we're going to make the same arguments
again today as last week
so it's important we address that but we
judge nvidia's actions
based on its msrp tells us what it's
doing what it thinks the market will pay
and that's important for us when
evaluating the card and how it's meant
to be positioned
and also addressing some of the comments
that a 3080 ti at 1200 is a great
deal compared to a scalp 3080. sure
that's true in the same way that i'd
rather get
shot in the arm than shot in the face
but in the same way benchmarks are like
for like
the market conditions when you make
these comparisons for our reviews have
to be like for like you can't compare
scalps to not scalp they need to either
both be msrp or both be scalped
to make a value determination except for
the specific instance where you have
only one of those two options
and you personally are choosing an
action on whether to buy or not buy but
we can't judge based on
the instances you run into only so let's
get into the benchmarks finally
frequency validation is up first
always useful for helping to find the
operating range of a card and making
sure that it's working properly
the 3080 ti operated around 1875 to 1890
megahertz after steady state thermals
with the 3080s original launch results
plotting higher
at 1930 megahertz or so the 3070 ti
plots between these two
and the card initially spikes to about
1950 megahertz but as the load ramps and
the temperature climbs
it falls to a relatively steady 1905
megahertz
there are a few spikes up and down but
for the most part it's
more stable as a line than its flanking
components
that means we're less power limited here
where you'd typically be bouncing
against
power limits and seeing more core
fluctuations as a result of course
it is still power limited but not to the
same extreme degree as some of the
higher end cards up next we'll plot the
core temperature versus rpm response on
the 3070 ti
as a reminder fans spin based on the v
bios temperature target and
really nothing else so the memory
temperature doesn't dictate fan rpm at
least not on this card
nor does any other component temperature
the 3070 ti core ramps to about
76 degrees celsius in a 21c environment
tested with 3dmark 100 core workloads
and at this point it rests at steady
state the fan ramps around 1730 rpm
initially
but you'll see a plateau both fans are
in sync here as well by the way
and then they climb to about 1850 to
1900 rpm to sustain
the initial fan rpm and the ramp slows
down
and nearly plateaus before climbing an
extra 100 to 200 rpm
which is an audible change in noise type
and in volume
typically we want to see more hysteresis
here to reduce the instant acoustic hit
as that's a lot more noticeable to a
human user than a gradual ramp is
thus far it's in line with other cars we
have the 3080ti
plotted here too just for reference next
we'll look at the core and memory
thermals during the same test
for this testing we used software and
hardware and
memory temperatures were measured using
software but validated with physically
attached thermocouples to the memory
packages
the workload remains 3dmark here so it's
more similar to gaming while other
workloads like furmark
stress vrm components more the 3070 ti's
hot spot temperature plotted in the
upper 80s when tested in our 21c
environment that's
fine there's not a lot of room for aging
or a bad case
but the gpu fans should adjust if they
almost climb higher
the memory plotted in the 80s which is
also fine
we're well within spec here rather than
the usual sort of barely technically
spec so that's an improvement from
nvidia it's possible that other
workloads stress the memory more than
here but thus far it's looking better
than the 90 to 100c range that we've
seen on the 3080ti
gaming benchmarks are up next now i like
the 3080 for the 3080ti review we re-ran
the 30-70 numbers because there has been
an improvement
since the last time we tested it the
improvements somewhere in the range of
3.4
to about 4.6 depending on what game it
was
so the 30-70 has been freshly retested
and the 3080
also has been retested the 6800 series
has seen no movement from last time we
did do a validation pass and we're
mostly seeing changes in the 30 series
cards from drivers and other
advancements we'll start with tomb
raider and spend more time evaluating
the behaviors here
even if you don't play this game it's
good because it'll give us an
opportunity to hopefully better
understand the value of the cards
we'll speed the next ones up after this
shot of the tomb raider at 4k
had the 30 70 ti at 78 fps average with
low as well paced at 69
and 68 fps the 30-70 fe tiles
version was at 71 fps average allowing
the 30-70
tie a lead of about 9.8 percent in
exchange for a hundred dollars more
by comparison the 3080 holds a 26 lead
over the 30 70 ti
or a 38 lead over the 30 70
non-tie let's break that math down
simply the 3070 ti
is able to achieve 80 of the 30 80s
performance
for 86 of the price the 30-70
can achieve 73 of the 30-80s performance
for 71 of the price the value needle in
other words hasn't moved
we're in the same spot nvidia isn't
trying to help anyone but that was clear
when it decided to dilute its silicon
supply
into more skus at a higher asp back to
the chart the rx 6800 non-xt remains
about four percent ahead of the 3070 ti
on this one with the 6800 xt
closer to the 3080 than it is to the
3070 ti
at 1440p the 6800 pulls ahead further
and establishes a six percent lead of
the 3070 ti
with the 3080 at 163 fps average or 23
of that 30 3070 ti and the 3070
allows the ti a lead of seven percent
here which diminishes
from the 4k advantage it helped that
aligns with the change
to the gpu sm count more than anything
else and is what we'd expect
the 3070 ti holds 82 percent of the
3080s performance here with the 30-70
at 76 percent of the 3080s performance
similar to 4k but allowing the 30-70
to climb more in value relative to the
30-70 ti
at 1080p we become cpu bound and
encounter a limit of about 180 fps
average on the nvidia cards in this game
the 3080 and 3080ti and the 3070 ti
are all functionally equal not only in
average fps but also in one percent and
0.1
lows for frame time consistency there's
no value to be had at this resolution
other than the value of looking at your
video card and thinking
that guy from nvidia called this thing a
tie the geforce rtx 3080 ti
rainbow six siege at 4k had the 3070 ti
at 154 fps average
that establishes a gap of 7.7 percent
over the 30 70
non-high with the 3080 holding a lead of
the 6800 6800xt from amd is advantaged
to
the 70 cards of course but the 6800
is behind them at 4k at 1440p the 3070
ti did about 283 fps average
totally unplayable gross in fact
only pores would settle over such a low
frame rate and if you can't afford its
price tag then
it's not for you and you should keep
your pinky on your glass when you drink
because you haven't
earned the 3080 ti or the 30-70 tie now
please make way for paying customers as
we move on to 1080p
okay good now that we've gotten rid of
the peasants we can talk about 1080p
performance
the 3070 ti runs 396 fps average here
which means you need a 6800xc or a
3080ti
otherwise you are physically disallowed
from enjoying this game
it runs like a slideshow on the 3070 ti
assuming the slideshow is displaying a
new slide every two and a half
milliseconds
over the 30-70 the ti holds a four
percent lead for 20
more money that's one percent more
frames for every 25 dollars if you want
to break it down like that
so the value argument is again not that
strong
red dead redemption 2 is next at 4k the
3070 ti ran at 71 fps average a lead of
7.4 percent in exchange for 20
more money it's at least not as bad as
the 30 80 ti is a 71
price hike for 10 more performance in
some games
but maybe that was part of nvidia's plan
to make this one look better like a
decoy product
even still a hundred dollars for an
unnoticeable change in frame rate is a
rough value proposition
the 30 70 ti ends up this same 7.4
percent ahead of the 6800 roughly
with the 3080 holding a lead of 21 over
the 30 70 ti
for about 17 more money in msrp
that decoy product theory is looking
pretty good right now at 1440p
the rx 6800 climbs past the 3070 ti as
expected
but the two are functionally equal in
overall performance
it does bring nvidia closer to amd than
the 3070 previously allowed at this
price point
maybe contributing to the decision to
launch the ti as if from hubris because
nvidia doesn't like to give up
a top position in any category and
that's not a bad thing because
competition is what we want
but read the room and video the rtx 3070
ti out does the 3070 by about 6.3
percent here diminishing the value
the 3080 holds a lead of 18 over the 30
70 ti
at 1080p the 3080 ti is led massively by
the 6800 xt nitro
and the 6900 xt stock alike thanks in
part to
nvidia driver overhead while the 3070 ti
is about equal to the 6800 non-xt
the lead over the 30-70 non-ti is about
5.7
for the tie a pattern at this point has
emerged
if we had future sight the 30-70 ti's
feature would read
not worth it it'd also read money is
not in your future we're going to start
going through these a lot faster so you
can pause if you need more detail on any
single chart in three kingdoms at 4k the
370ti held a 9.9 percent advantage over
the 30-70 one of its peaks
the 6800 stock remains above both as a
reminder amd
holds a lowe's advantage in this title
versus nvidia at 1440p the 3070 ti
maintains an 8
gain over the 30 70 while the 6800
maintains a lead over the 3070 ti
of about three and a half percent 3080
boosts significantly higher than both
landing at about 94 fps average here
cyberpunk 2077 at 4k
high had the 3070 ti leading the 3070 by
8.4 percent
falling in line with the others the 3070
ti is a great gpu
for increasing the nvidia's average
selling price for shareholder confidence
at 1440p
the 3070 ti landed at 81 fps average
outpaced expectedly by the 6800 xt
and the 3080 the card is roughly tied
with the 6800 non-xt
and out does the 30-70 non-tie by about
5 fps average
so great at 1080p we see a 5.9 percent
advantage from the 3070 ti over the
30-70 at 119 fps
versus 112 average the 6800 lands
between them but the 30 series holds
better lows here than the 6800 does
enough rasterization we've made the
point so time to move on some lightly
ray traced titles
tomb raider at 4k will start us out with
ray tracing this is still mostly
rasterized just with rt shadows
so it is one of the easier rt workloads
and this one at 4k
the 3070 ti ran about 10 to 12 percent
ahead of the 3070
so it's a more meaningful percentage at
12 than we saw on most rasterization
tests nvidia maintains an advantage in
rt performance over amd
but this game's light use of rt does
mean that the 6800 is close by at 1080p
the 3070 ti maintains a nine and a half
percent lead over the 3070 back down to
the original difference and again
unexciting we ran a couple other rt
games as well
and scaling outside of minecraft is
mostly the same across them
or otherwise just not worth it so this
is pretty dull
and we know enough now that we can just
close out this review and skip the rest
of the games power consumption testing
is up last
this helps us determine the efficiency
this test scene is at the board level
and not at the wall so we are only
measuring the video card power
testing is comparable directly between
amd and nvidia
the rtx 3070 ti fe card pulled about 296
watts when stock
with the overclock pushing us to 326 on
the fe model
the original 3070 fe ran at about 225
watts
and amd's rx 6800 meanwhile pulls about
239 watts stock
the 6800 xt is at 294. so then
for efficiency the 3070 ti compared to
the 3070
is pulling about 31 percent more power
for
not that much percent more performance
so that's it for this one the 30 70 ti
is not worth purchasing purely based on
the performance of the price
the value proposition is not good it
scales better than the 3080 ti
but be careful of getting gaslighted
into thinking
that the 3070 ti is therefore a good
value just because the 3080 ti was much
worse
they're both bad value but the 3080ti
starts to look a bit like a decoy at the
high end
to trick you into thinking that the 30
70 ti
is better now maybe that's not what
nvidia's intent was it probably wasn't
they just want to sell silicon
but at the end of the day if you can get
a 30-70
the performance increase is functionally
irrelevant
it's very unlikely you'll notice the
frame rate difference in them and it's a
hundred dollars more
that hundred bucks is very noticeable
for a lot of people
it has an immediate impact on what else
you can buy or you could just save it
and use it for something else
in the future so and as always just a
reminder if you're happy with your
system today if you have older parts
like a 10 series or something you can do
a lot to stretch it
and make it last a little bit longer so
if you're happy with what you have
then keep using it you don't need to get
sucked into the upgrade cycle the people
who are going to be the most
uh in the most exposed position here
are those who are trying to complete a
build and don't have an existing build
that they can use
especially people who need it for work
or
you need a hobby and escape gaming is it
and you can't
get a gpu and you don't have an old one
that's where
you have the most exposure to getting
ripped off uh but you also
probably have the most invested in
trying to buy one but if you're pretty
happy with what you have
you could leave it alone and write it
out for a little bit longer
if your card is still good no no reason
to create more e-waste anyway hold on
you could probably scalp it yourself
and make some more money but that's the
only value of the 30-70 ti
is uh buying it with intent to resell
otherwise
the other cards just offer a lot more
3080 and 3070 included
and the rx 6800 is in a decent position
as well but nvidia still remains
dominant
in ray tracing specific performance so
that's it for this one
thanks for watching as always subscribe
for more you can go to
store.gamersnexus.net
or patreon.com gamersnexus to help us
out directly and we'll see you all next
time